Good morning John.
This may have been the second oddest weekend of my life.
I perused Portland real estate with a Mythbuster's wife on an iPad owned by Adam Savage.
Yes you can say that my perception of reality was ravaged. But imagine, that wasn't even the weirdest bit.
And you're gonna **** a brick when you hear the rest of it.
So sit down and listen to me rhythmically talk about the weekend that I participated in w00tstock.
Now I'm on a plane home and I just want to remember it - hearing Adam Savage saying that he likes my music.
And I've been listening to Frontalot - 200 tracks back to back which is probably why I wrote out this song as a rap
but I hope whoever sits in 9D next doesn't gag because I'm writing down these lyrics on the back of a barf bag.
For me, it began when I landed in Seattle at 2 o'clock and then I had 3 hours talking with the king of nerd hip hop.
MC Frontalot, as he's professionally known, could probably cure cancer with his headlamp and a microphone.
And then Molly walked in with her adorable grin and her boyfriend Chris and her assistant Kristin.
Two girls, one uke, don't fear, it won't make you puke unless you're easily nauseated by things abnormally cute.
And then I felt that I was losing control of my brain because the drummer of the Presidents of the USA
was hanging with me, making jokes, telling me to be strong, like he jumped straight out of my tape player and into my song.
And then my friend Stephen Toulouse walked by. He decides who lives and dies on Xbox Live..
He's the guy with the ban hammer on the largest gaming platform. And we were all brought here by messers Paul and Storm
who were in good form and bought the pizza that I was eatin' when I learned just how nerdy was the nerd Wil Wheaton.
He was adorably excited, jumping up and down. His smile was the inverse function of a frown, taken to 1024th power.
I did my best not to fangirl for the whole next hour. And then I was on the stage ostensibly earning my wage.
Picard had thrown me into overdrive and said "engage".
My cheeks hurt from laughing, it was so much freaking fun.
Savage, Fraction, Frontalot and Loading Ready Run and then done.
And we were up there taking our bow, like wow, the crowd's so loud that I could not understand how this had happened to me, I mean I'm just another geek.
Well last week, it had a freaking unique streak. Just a couple of days ago the world was planting me trees
and now I'm up in front of a thousand geeks living my dreams.
I'm prepared to accept this is the pinnacle of my career, I don't mind if it's all downhill from here
because here's a pretty good place to be downhill from, I mean there's an awful lot of hill there before you hit the bottom.
And in the morning, my goodness, I saw that Wil Wheaton had pulled out his Blackberry and done some tweeting.
He tweeted I killed it and from what he could hear my set, of all of those at w00tstock, got the biggest cheer.
I'm not really concerned about whether this is true or not, it just makes me pretty grateful there's a thing call w00tstock.
Yeah, w00tstock.
It's a rap that I did about w00tstock.
And the beat, the beat is, the beat just keeps going?
When do I stop?
I-I don't have any more words... O-Okay
John, how is this my life?
The show went really well, if I do say so myself. Everyone was hilarious the whole time and my part went well too.
So I'm putting the link in my pants down here so that you can go check it out.
And there will also be an annotation at the end of the video, which is just about right now.
So John, I will see you on Friday in which you answer some awesome Nerdfighter questions. Bye bye!